non pas dit qu'elle était malade elle et
ses quatre chaises mini psy et les oies
partie était malade depuis l'annoncé du
décès du cosec de 700 pages michel
myrtille employé au service de sécurité
de la mairie de paris
ses parents et amis défilent au domicile
de sa soeur rosemary o'rourke la
martinique une soeur ébranlé par l'appel
de médecins de l'hôpital lariboisière
mardi dernier
il m'a demandé est ce que ma soeur
habite à la houppe
paris la wii du look et dit oui et m'a
dit que ma sony a pris en urgence
j'ai demandé au dr
déjà c'est les malades d'un super tri
n'est pas ce que vous devez mais m'a dit
après qu'il ait que des décédés
c'est tout ce qu'il m'a dit c'est tout
ce que j'ai pu j'ai dit à mon mari de
téléphone parce que j'étais 3 foulée le
pouvaient pas écouté luis l élu mais par
quoi elle est décédée
j'avais mal et là je peux pas vous dis
moi je ne sais pas c'est à elle m'a
reconnu selon quelques éléments
communiqués par la famille il semblait
que mishima qui souffrait de maux de
tête
elle se serait d'abord rendu à la
clinique où elle consulté par médecin
traitant puis elles ont été transférés
en urgence par les pompiers à l'hôpital
lariboisière et c'est là tout le mystère
autour de sa mort
que s'est il réellement passé dans la
nuit de lundi à mardi aux urgences
se souvenant quand même enlevé là on
l'appelle on l'appelle n'est pas parti à
l'application la retrouver mode sur son
banc car c'est qu'elle n'a jamais laissé
les lieux
une autopsie du corps a été pratiquée au
quai de la rapée à paris par un médecin
légiste
dans l'attenté des résultats et à
l'appui de leurs avocats la famille
espère connaître enfin les circonstances
précises du décès de cette célibataire
de 55 ans